welcome everybody uh
i'll talk by eric banker on a
binary interactive mapping approach
okay
can you hear me
so first of all thank you uh
thank you to the organizers for inviting
me and giving me the opportunity to
speak at this really exciting meeting
my lab works on
on on protein protein interaction
protein protein interaction technologies
now for quite some time and in this talk
i i want to focus on on various
approaches various efforts we have
to to generate protein protein
interaction data i want to speak about
limitations we currently have in terms
of the data sets
uh and and then also give you a few
examples about uh interesting proteins
or interesting protein protein
interactions
that that we work on in in the lab
um i i think i think it is
clear and
it doesn't need much of explanation that
that proteins do not function in
isolation they rather have to form
complexes protein complexes or various
types of complexes
uh in in order to
uh uh generate function and um in i
think it's it's clear from from what you
already have heard if we want to
understand
how a genotype gets converted into a
phenotype
in a cell or in a whole organism we have
to understand the the underlying
molecular networks much more
comprehensively as we do this uh today
and um
we
we and this is this is uh uh
important and this brings us to to the
the
the quantification or the to the to the
measurement of protein protein
interactions and
if you think about this this is not a
simple problem or it's not a simple uh
issue because you you cannot have a
machine now where you put in all your
your cells or your cell extracts and at
the end you get protein interactions out
like like a sequencing machine
the issue is that protein protein
interactions are very diverse they they
have they have very different
affinities you have
very stable protein complexes where
where you were where a complex risk
resists
even hours and then you have very
transient interactions you have a lot of
regulation
in terms of protein protein interactions
so it is definitely not something where
you have one easy method and
and you will
you will get them all and specifically
in in the last years uh from from from
the vidal group and from others it is
clear that the protein protein
interaction networks are dominated by
weak very transient interactions
that are definitely very hard to catch
or to to identify
and this is one
issue we have to face as a field i think
but there is also
another important point
that that we have learned from from
previous studies is that genetic
mutations or or omissions mutations
uh that
make subtle changes so basically one
amino acid change in a protein is
sufficient to change
the interaction map to change the
interaction uh
situation so you will have a gain of
interactions through certain uh missense
mutations but you will have also a loss
of interactions
and this brings us to to the to the
question of annotations we are we are
still used to map these
proteins or protein interactions onto
the gene level i really think we as a
field need to go and map and annotate
this interaction on the amino acid
sequence level to be uh to be on the
right and to go into the right direction
so in in a way which is currently not
the case and i think you have you all
know we have protein variants we have
fragments we have a lot of uh
points here so i think this is something
we have to do as a field we have to come
to a new way of annotating protein
protein interactions
um just to to give you an uh what we are
interested in the lab we we focus on
genetic mainly we focus on on genetic
protein protein interaction detection
essays and and this includes the the
yeast to hybrid this includes various
type of genetics tools and the the
essential
issue here is that we that we use tact
protein we express them in in different
cells and we we are measuring these
protein interactions indirectly either
by by uh measuring the the energy
transfer like bioluminescence energy
transfer or by the yeast to hybrid where
we have a reported gene that then gets
quantified
and
this is this is in in a bit different
from the biochemical
vessels where proteins are enriched
via antibodies or affinity tags and
where you at the end
get some sort of protein composition
data you don't know exactly who is
interacting with whom you have you can
never be sure whether there are direct
contacts
and uh just to for uh to give you an
idea how we what we do we have in the
lab we have generated or developed an
automated yeast to hybrid system
where we have basically automated all
various steps from from from the data
generation to the analysis we use
speaking and spotting robots and with
this technology we can now test
about 70 000 protein interaction pairs
per week and we have a library
that contains about 17 000 human
cdnas that is arrayed and can be
systematically screened for
protein-protein interactions
and um
just for the for the for the people here
what is the the principle how is this
possible to to to do we use a a method
that that is already was
quite old which we call interaction
mating approach so in a way we have two
different e strains an alpha and an a
strain and we express the debate and the
bray protein in these individual strains
and this allows us to make a matrix uh
which then you
by just making this you get diploids
yeasts and then you score for protein
protein interactions and when you when
you when you do this in an automated way
just that you get an idea how this looks
like this is we use quite large agar
plates where we spot on
the yeast
cells and here each dot is a is a yeast
strain which contains a pair of
potential interacting proteins
and you can see around thousand of these
yeast colonies and this is where you
just control that more or less all of
them grow on on the ag and then you
basically spot this onto a selective
plate and only protein pairs that
contain
interactions can grow
and when you when you when you do this
and this is this is what we
what we do in a very systematic and
automated way you you have uh
imaging we have imaging software tools
where you just automatically uh score or
identify interacting proteins we have a
database and then with the end we have
software tools as many of you already
have you have seen which then converts
this binary interaction data into
protein protein interaction networks
and
this this works uh more or less uh in an
automated or a semi-automated we have to
always
check by hand or by by so to to at the
end have have this uh high quality
data and just an example uh from from a
study we we have done quite recently
together with with wrote it uh we we
generated a an interaction map or
protein protein interaction data set
that we call neuronet uh where we co
where we where we had the idea of of of
finding links between proteins that are
involved in different neurodegenerative
diseases so starting with with
alzheimer's parkinson's huntington's
this is various uh neurodegenerative
diseases and what what we found was that
indeed on the protein level if you
generate all these data
you see links that uh that that occur
between for example parkinson's disease
and huntington's disease or even als in
terms of of the involvement of certain
proteins in in in various diseases and
when you have this this data
you can you can run a
a network propagation algorithms like uh
the one that was developed by rhodet so
so in a way you start with a certain
amount of proteins that you use as seeds
and then you you you propagate the
network and at the end you get
high highly connected protein clusters
that are reflecting certain diseases or
potential disease
states and just to give you an example
this is this is published
we this is a parkinson's disease uh
module as we call this very highly
connected proteins several proteins are
known or have been found previously but
there are also proteins like this icosec
one which hasn't been linked before and
so we we looked at this specifically in
a in a
model c elegance model and could see
when we knock out these proteins it
dramatically increases the aggregation
of the synuclein protein that is a key
player
in in parkinson's disease now we know
that this is not just a protein that is
relevant for parkinson's this is also
relevant for alzheimer's disease and
huntington's disease or
another
example from from how you can use this
this network information which is a
network model for alzheimer's disease
that that was defined based on on the
network
propagation algorithm and then we we use
this and asked the question are these
proteins abnormally folded up normally
aggregates so do these proteins
lead to
to
aggregated molecules and we looked at
um we looked at postmodern brains of
patients and controls and indeed found
that a large fraction of the proteins
that were were defined here are
abnormally aggregated in the brain of of
alzheimer's disease
patients and so so we came up with what
we call a model or idea of alzheimer's
disease that alzheimer's disease is is a
multi-aggregation disease so in a at the
stage where where you have symptoms so
when
when uh that there are many more
aggregated misfolded protein
in the in the brain than than previously
expected there are certain candidates
that we know for many years this is tau
that is a beta but but as we think is
there many many more of these proteins
this is very relevant i we think because
if all the clinical trials to treat
alzheimer's disease have failed
and they always work with symptoms more
or less with symptomatic patients so if
you if you perturb or if you take out a
protein
at this at this
relatively late stage of disease you
might have no no chance at all because
the other aggregates the other proteins
are already there and this is this is
what we currently propose so you have to
start much earlier and we now know that
you have maybe to start 20 15 to 20
years uh before you have symptoms with
interfering
of this aggregation misfolding process
so that's just an example for for neural
degeneration but now now to this do this
data we we are generating uh with the
yeast to hybrid there are two in my view
two very important limitations which the
field or many people in the field not
often don't like to speak about which is
on one hand these these data sets the
yeast to hybrid essay as we do it in the
lab and you see it here if you do it you
have heard from pascal if you do it in a
very uh precise so if you do a benchmark
way is not very sensitive so if you have
hundred proteins which are well protein
interactions which are known where you
have literature and you run them through
the essay at
the fast discovery rate of one percent
or even lower you will get a sensitivity
of around 20 25
and so that means a lot of information a
lot of
protein protein interactions with the
yeast hybrid method are missed and i
think even if you if you do this uh 20
times or if you repeat these experiments
this this is in my view and an important
issue or a limitation of this of this
method and another limitation we have
when we generate these networks and is
that you have yes or no answers so you
see yeast growth but you have no
information about the affinity you have
no information about the strengths of
protein-protein interactions and this is
why we have started already five years
ago with the development of a new method
which we call lucy and this is a a
quantitative method which uh a two
hybrid method where we use
bioluminescence
uh based readout and in in a way there
are two things that that i i like about
this is there is one you have uh you get
two readouts for each protein protein
interaction that that you are analyzing
so first you measure in the cell so you
just use a bioluminescence energy
transfer from another luciferase onto
your your your fluorophore like m
citrine and this is the the first
readout and then you lyse the cell and
you get for the same interaction you do
an an immunoprecipitation or an uh let
me call
look where you where you get another
measurement of the nanoluciferase bound
to the protein complex
and uh this this is something we we we
have we can do now in in 384 well blades
uh and when you when you do the
benchmarking with this this essay you
can see this here we have done this
together also with our colleagues from
from the vidal lab uh we used a positive
reference set and we use the negative
references or random references and when
we do this analysis and say we want to
have no interaction in our negative set
we can still detect uh 71 of the protein
protein interactions right so and if you
if you look at this this is the double
readout method now this is the classical
methods yeast to hybrid map it many of
these
techniques are out there
it's it's basically all in the range of
of i would say 30 to 40 50 and we we are
now up here and um what i think is
interesting as well when we now go for a
reference set of of interactions that
are structurally uh uh
supported so in a way just taking
interactions whether is this crystal
structure or or available for this
protein complex
then we even and we combine this
yeast to this lucid technology with uh
with other technologies that are out
there we can even go up to almost 100
percent so we we we tested this set and
uh we except of one interactions all
interactions were scored so i think we
we can dramatically
increase the sensitivity of these these
methods and that in my view might have
huge implications if you then later on
uh do network propagation or or really
look at biology and uh we we have just
to to to give you an idea we have now
automated also this technique and you
can see here the this is a mammalian
cells we we are not by far not at the
level where we where we have been with
the yeast to hybrid but but at the
moment we can do about thousand protein
bears protein interactions but weak with
this with this technology and i think if
we would uh would go into this a bit a
bit more and and we we could we could uh
at least get five to ten fold higher
numbers of protein protein interactions
to be screened
um just to to because this is this was
always a an issue of of
uh and pascal mentioned it that that
that with these two hybrid data or
methods you you don't see interactions
that are normally found in protein
complexes and so we we produced what we
call a reference set for for three
protein complexes so you have here uh
each complex five to six proteins that
are that this
these complexes are known on on they
have been found with proteomics there is
structural information available um and
so we we scored this these uh
complexes and with our binary method and
what you can see here is that
at very stringent conditions so there is
no we didn't allow any intercomplex uh
interactions to occur so
we we and at the end what you can see
here maybe it's a little bit too small
we can detect
again
for one complex even ninety percent for
the others around seventy percent of
these protein protein interactions in in
these protein complexes so in a way i i
believe
that by combining binary interaction
tools with with mass spec based methods
we might generate networks that are of
of of much higher quality and and
biological relevance then then then we
do this today
and uh just a a an example of a protein
we work in the lab now just as also as a
surprise
which is the hunting team protein this
is an alpha helical protein it leads to
leads to genetic disease with an
expanded polyglutamine sequence i i i
don't want to go into this in detail but
when we many protein interactions have
been found for this protein but when we
map this with our new techniques we have
a we have a set of protein protein
interactions that definitely uh uh bind
to the full length protein we see some
some
involvement of the protein in in
endocytosis and autophagy and we get
quantitative data uh for certain
proteins so we see clearly that at least
one protein is binding there is very
high affinity to the huntington product
this is the hub 40 protein here you can
see this here by by by looking at the
binding strengths
and we we did uh mutations to disrupt
this protein complex you can can see
this here we can we can see that that if
we introduce certain
amino acid changes in the hub 40 protein
the interaction can be inhibited and
what was very interesting to see was
that if we look if we do not crispr
knockouts in hex cells
we knock out the hunting team protein
the hub40 protein is completely gone so
huntingtin holds the the hub 40 protein
uh like uh some sort of a holding
chaperone and uh if the hunting team
gets lost the the the hub 40 protein
gets lost we can bring back the protein
by co-expressing the hub 40 protein
again into into this into this model and
um so so we now have evidence that this
is a functional complex and i'm not
going to go into this and other proteins
are binding to this complex and hub40 is
dependent on on for the association of
other proteins to this this hunting team
a molecule
and just to do to what to give you an
idea what we can do with with this uh
breadth-based technology but we can
introduce the the the luciferase and the
fluorophores different
regions in the hunting team protein and
we can use these tags as a molecular
ruler to to to measure distances so if
you if you add the the the huntingtin
without the hub40 protein comes you see
a molecular change in in this protein
and you can you can monitor the the
potential distances and we have uh
structural information that fit very
well with our data
we have so you can get very deep in
terms of the the understanding of
specific protein complexes if you if
you're interested and another protein we
work and this is a molecular machine in
the lab it's a triple a atpase it's p97
it's uh
involved in various diseases in als but
also in cancer and what was very
surprising this is a normally this
protein is a very symmetric molecule you
see this here it's a very stable
hexamere and
what we were expecting if you just look
at the notes uh that this the proteins
bind do this to this hexameter but when
we looked into a bit more in detail
into the we found a protein that's
called espl that not just binds to the
heck somewhere this is what we thought
will happen but when it binds it was
able to disassemble the complex and and
convert this into hetero oligomers so
you need it
you need at some point you you see
surprises in a way in terms of protein
which and you can see this this works
basically because the espl protein forms
some sort of hilarious structure which
wraps around of a of a specific domain
the end domain uh in in p97 and disrupts
this this complex and we have now and
this is this is work in progress we have
now shown that aspl is important for the
binding of another protein to to p97
which is u2 f2 this is a
splicing very important splicing factor
and you can see only if
if the espl protein is present the
splicing factor can bind to b97 and when
we knock out this aspl protein we have a
massive effect on the splicing in our
cell in our cell model and we can also
show this endogenously that the protein
interaction gets disrupted
and just because you have heard a lot of
of cobit we also did a small uh kobe
project where we just were interested to
find high confidence protein protein
interact viral protein so we were not
interested in the host viral interaction
you have seen but we were interested to
see high confidence interaction in in in
in the virus in the viral proteins and
we used a
machine learning where a support vector
type of of of
approach to classify this high
confidence interaction so interaction
with a high probability we identified we
tested all these 26 viral protein
against each other we found 30 proteins
that were
found reproducibly we then
looked at
one of these proteins nsp16 and nsp10 in
detail uh we mapped the the the binding
region we could show where this protein
interact then we did the docking with in
silico docking we we screened basically
uh
i think it was 200 million potential
compounds and found at the end one one
molecule that binds now with reasonable
affinity and we are currently
characterizing this this
compound and do structure
structure function relationship analysis
and finally just another method we
developed recently in the lab which we
we call selfie and here the the issue is
that a lot of this mess a lot of the
networks you have seen from from from
the colleagues are all generated with
over expression of of proteins in a
model system and that can lead to
abnormal in my view abnormal protein
protein interaction so i would say that
a lot of the data out there that we have
and we use as the basis for modeling
might have interactions that that or
include interactions at least to some
extent
that might not occur in in the
endogenous conditions and so we what we
did here we use the cell line which is
called e-hub this is a haploid cell line
brenda knows
this so in a way we use crispr to to to
knock in with uh
sorry
we use crispr to knock in
yeah
our target
reporters and then we fuse the cells we
do electro fusion we get diploid cells
and we can score endogenous protein
protein interactions for example again
the aspl you have heard before with p97
you you only see a signal when when
these two proteins interact or we used
another protein this is tdp-43 this is
involved in in
ils
so again you just see a signal and we
can you can use these cell lines then
also to screen for protein protein
interactions and and and and
do password analysis so just to to
summarize um what we believe is that
that you need complementary protein
protein interaction essays to really get
data that that that are comprehensive
um
and
we strongly believe that by combination
of affinity purification mass
spectrometry various types of data sets
we we will be able to to create the
basis
to really understand biological
functions of multi-protein complexes and
the future i think is is really looking
at endogenous protein complexes this is
something we have not there yet but i
think with crispr it is possible um
and and and um i i really believe also
that the understanding of
of of or maybe we need to focus on
certain processes on certain modules to
to get high quality data and then go and
ex expand this these activities just
this is most important slide work has
been done by chris three post dogs chris
secker philippe trepta and also uh
christian hennig who who did a lot on
the on the on the development of the
essays and many many other people were
involved uh thank you very much for your
intention
hi
so i was
wondering about
your comment on
so it's possible that basically once you
have a seat then any proteins has made a
better fold of kind of flavor would
would come and and extend this and
participate and is that testable with
this type of history but
it's maybe not so easy testable with
these
two hybrid methods but in principle you
can have this propagation right you can
have this i think i think what is what
is both accepted is
homologous cd which is so you have a
protein a and you will take in the other
protein which is which is the same
sequence but there's only exactly there
but there's also heterogeneity which is
not so well
well described and people are still
arguing but i think especially in
alzheimer's there's now more and more
evidence that the beta can somehow lead
to the aggregation of tau and it's also
the other way around we are studying
this also in our fly models so so so
that's that's one thing and then you
have additional proteins that will maybe
be recruited into these structures that
are that can have can come in via
another mechanism because just as an
example if you when we always see
when we make this type of misfolded
proteins then the japanese system will
react and the chaperones will go to the
aggregate and they will try to
dissociate this but when they are stable
so they are at some point also part of
the complex so you will have a loss of
function of
you know hsp 90 is super important in
many processes
regulates kinases and that will also
contribute to the phenotype so so it's
it's it's complicated but in principle
uh i think this is this is where we what
we have to look at and and i think you
can dissect it we didn't do this we you
need other methods but you can dissect
it
so it's possible like to have a yeast
that has
already on this
uh you know and then you killed all this
he shot putting another chocolate shot
and see if it's i i have to say we do
this with um with the flyers actually
this this is basically these dots you
see here this is hunting team aggregates
right they are they are light up
this is basically a fret signal and you
can see the eyes here you see a brain
and then it's a certain point it's full
with with these aggregates and it
recruits a lot of other proteins into
these aggregates and that leads them to
a
rapid death of the flies so
uh this is this is the
way to study this and we now know that
you even small amount of aggregates are
sufficient so we can turn on the protein
expression for
three days we turn it off and still the
amount of aggregate will be sufficient
to kill the the fly
sorry yeah it was wonderful sorry
yeah you wanna okay oh i actually have a
follow-up question
you can take the class
from
yeah i mean we did a lot on this
in our
mouse models so you can look at these by
proteomics you can cut out the glass and
there is a nice paper where people need
expression profiles so you can look at
the transcription
there you can look at the proteins or
your various studies
the reality is that you have hundreds of
proteins there actually in there
or associated
with this with this aggregate
um
and and and so so this is possible this
is something we we
do the questions what are the relevant
ones and how do they
how do they uh
get there
um but that's that's easy right in the
meantime yeah with high resolution
probiotics okay it's probably
fascinating to see shackles
usually chaperones are there
uh
the whole ubiquitin system is there
right so so they cannot do it so so it's
a massive i always see it as a massive
collapse
of
of these of these systems and
and at a certain point it's too late to
do something this is something we have
to realize
and that's why i'm i'm always a bit uh
worried when people do a
more political trust we have to start
very early with the measure the disease
20 years before you see something then
you have a chance
energy transfer it's the same principle
i'm sorry i didn't explain this so you
have the nano luciferase okay and then
you would use any green because this is
this is a bit even more sensitive than
mc3 and
that is all you need to to see a signal
i have to say this is still a limitation
again from from this method you
definitely see you need a certain
expression level of of your proteins
that endogenously expressed right
so so so
there's definitely something where where
you mind if you have a protein that is
energetically expressed at a very low
level you can write you use the
transcript levels and you can look at
this then then
um
then you might not see an interaction
because it's it's not sensitive enough
but
we we tested so it's more work to do
what we did is the first
set of proteins
about the limitations of the technology
as far as i could understand you always
measure which is directly independently
can you also measure what happens
simultaneously or if it's
not feasible with these approaches
i mean i have to think a bit more i
think but uh
it's
not easy because
uh i
the moment i would say we cannot because
this would really give us a lot of
information that is missing from the
method yeah i mean to to some extent
you you could i mean with thinking about
this right you could with crispr into
integrate certain texts i mean i think
you could do this
simultaneously
for a certain number of proteins that
you define in your network and then you
see how they change uh either with
stimulation or or anyway so in a way
creating some sort of a reporter system
which reads the physiology of the cell
but that that is doable i think but not
on a real big scale because you're
limited to the to the to the molecules
you're fusing
but in principle
you could you could think about this
so now i have the head of my structural
biology background
so we we have seen that i mean most of
the methods are interaction discovery
methods that you're exploring are based
on fusible proteins yeah and what we
have seen is that whenever either the n
or the c terminal of one of the proteins
within 20 answers of the interface it
doesn't matter what linker you use or it
doesn't matter what expression vector
you use you're never gonna detect this
interaction so it could be that we are
already pretty close at the completion
of the type of interactions that these
uh
that these fusion-based technologies can
detect
and then the the other opponents that i
didn't get when you explore
using luffy
whether you reconstitute the the
full complexes
i don't know whether you meant the
direct interactions between the
complexes or all the potential
interactions between the complexes
because then again i mean maybe we're
hitting everything here because not all
the proteins within a complex are in the
right one yeah yeah no no you you i i
meant the direct interactions within the
complex and you can nicely see i i
didn't go into this that certain uh i
mean this is a rewriting of five
proteins and a protein on the outside
and you
not you're not seeing this interaction
let's say of protein a
with protein d which is on the other
side of the complex so so
um
and it's it's it's all about the
distance uh measurements we we
do
one important point is that we now have
to do the tagging
at
n and c in all orientations right so so
that's also what we we haven't done
before and that also increases the
sensitivity uh enormously
yeah but i mean there's there's
something like seven percent of all the
interactions
that even i mean it's both so it's the
the n and the c of both proteins that
are within 20 answers of the interface
so this this seven percent i mean you
will always miss yeah
that's true
yeah that's that's why we we need to
talk about these things right
now there's something we've done with
with uh mark
i don't remember whether it's published
or not but certainly
okay
thank you very much